I started playing here at East Beach when I was seven years old with my parents...
...and I have never stayed away from this beach...
...for longer than, probably nine months; it's been a great place for me.
All my life, it's kept me in shape and kept me with a bunch of friends...
...that I've gotten to know over the years...
...and played volleyball with and hung out with.
If you go from Point Conception, south of the Mexican border along the coast,...
...this really is the center of beach volleyball for the United States.
The United States has had gold medalists over the years for beach volleyball...
...because of Southern California.
Well, East Beach has probably the best courts and best lines...
...and overall best facilities, maybe up and down the coast.
I can't think of another beach that has this many courts...
...that are this good in shape and it's been like that forever.
Ever since I've been playing down here, it's been the same.
I have to thank the city of Santa Barbara for that.
But that really, that consistency, has made this place great.
That allows everybody to come down here week after week,...
...month after month, always know that they have a place,...
...that's family-friendly and volleyball-friendly.
Nothing has changed though development has occured and it's gorgeous.
That makes East Beach so much better, you can just come down here...
...and really get a good workout and really good volleyball.